[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique
un peu plus d'une semaine de la rentrée
pour de nombreux salariés français un
protocole strict pour les employeurs a
été présentée aujourd'hui par le
ministère du travail la nation qui tient
grâce au travail c'est ce qu'a déclaré
emmanuel macron dans son discours du 1er
mai et ce travail il est effectué en
grande partie par les gilet jaune la
nation tient elle grâce à eux c'est la
question de notre débat ce soir nous
sommes avec florian philippot conseiller
régional du grand est et président des
patriotes et face à vous ce soir jean
paul huchon président honoraire du
conseil régional ile de france
bonsoir à tous les deux ravis de vous
retrouver merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france on va d'abord écouter la
déclaration du président français et on
en débat juste après l'esprit du 1er mai
cet esprit de solidarité entre les
travailleurs n'a peut-être jamais été
aussi puissant aussi vivant car c'est
bien grâce au travail célébrée ce jour
que la nation tient et c'est grâce à eux
que la nation tient florian philippot le
président a remercié toute la
distribution alimentaire les caissières
les agriculteurs ceux qui transportent
les marchandises qui nous ont nourris
pendant ce déconfinement ces personnes
là ce sont bien les gilet jaune bas ce
sont évidemment les jaunes
ce sont les gens qu'il ya encore
quelques mois nous coûter un pognon de
dengue a écouté présent la république
moi je pense que non il ne le montre pas
évidemment mais macron est ko debout
parce qu'en fait c'est tout sur logiciel
qui qui s'écroule c'est son monde qui
s'écroule et les gens qu'il a souvent
maltraité les a traités tous les noms on
s'en souvient les gens qui ne sont qu
ils ne sont rien
les îles et traite c'est en réalité on
se rend compte enfin ils se rencontrent
parce qu'on n'était quand même pas mal à
le savoir avant que ce sont les gens qui
ont tourné le pays sont les caissières
sont les infirmières sont les pompiers
va ce sont les huit ans d'autres les
livreurs etc
ce sont effectivement des gens qu'on a
beaucoup retrouver fin 2018 sur les
ronds points qu'on avait retrouvé dans
les manifestations et qui avait
simplement des revendications de bon
sens dont on se rend compte qu'elles
sont quand même à
demandes légitimes sur leur pouvoir
d'achat sur la destruction du service
public donc c'est grâce à eux que le que
le pays a tenu
jean paul huchon c'est votre avis
également il va falloir les remercier
aussi ces gens là il ya une continuité
dans cette histoire de france
aujourd'hui les gilet jaune avec
beaucoup de gens modestes qui faisait de
la rue mais qu'il n'y arrivait pas les
grèves pour la soi disant réforme des
retraites qui ne reprend pas lieu et
puis maintenant cette crise sanitaire et
dans tous les cas ce sont les plus
modestes parfois les plus tes classes et
ceux qui n'ont pas bénéficié de
promotions ou d'emplois nouveaux qui
s'étire à qui sont en première ligne
donc en effet on a envie de les
remercier
on a envie de dire aussi que le monde
dans lequel nous allons vivre sur un
monde qui reconnaîtra peut-être
davantage les plus pauvres les plus
modestes et ceux qui travaillent
vous pensez que ce sera le cas florian
philippot on va s'en souvenir de ce
patriotisme dans quelconque quelque sens
on est obligé enfin je veux dire si on
veut pas une révolution
durée sanglante on est obligé de faire
une révolution politique c'est à dire
c'est à dire de bad annulée si vous
voulez tout ce qui est suspendu pour
l'instant et qui tape en priorité cette
population là c'est à dire la réforme de
l'assurance chômage la réforme des
retraites qui sont aujourd'hui suspendu
mais info il faut les annuler et puis on
va être on va devoir réfléchir sur
l'augmentation réelle du smic on va
devoir réfléchir sur le dégel du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires qui est
honteusement gelé depuis dix ans la sq a
aussi beaucoup de fonctionnaires parmi
ces gens c'est gilet jaune c'est les
gens qui ont fait tourner et qui font
tourner le pays pendant cette crise
donc il est évident que moi je pense que
si on veut s'éviter quelque chose de
très violents et très dur on va devoir
donner beaucoup faire une révolution
politique au bon sens du terme et je
sais que ça n'est pas partagée j'ai
entendu mois le président du medef
geoffroy roux de bézieux dire qu'après
la crise il faudrait s'attendre à
baisser les congés payés à augmenter le
temps de travail
je pense que ça serait absolument
scandaleux de faire payer les victimes
de la crise à la place des coupables
et puis de faire payer ceux qui ont
permis justement
au pays de tenir oui le message de
d'emmanuel macron se voulait rassembleur
pour ce 1er mai il a remercié donc les
travailleurs mais il a eu un mot
malheureux écouter qui a été commentée
notamment par
alexis corbière privé des rituels de
cette journée nous en éprouvons
aujourd'hui toute la valeur tout le sens
avec cette volonté forte
retrouvez dès que possible
les premiers mais joyeux chamailleurs
parfois qui font notre nation message
est symptomatique de la condescendance
réac de ce président non les premiers
mais ne sont pas chamailleurs mai
revendicatif
non le 1er mai ne célèbre pas le travail
mais la lutte des travailleurs ale des
premiers mais chamailleurs un jean paul
huchon le président s'attend donc à ce
que quand on reviendra à la normale
n'est encore des manifestations c'est
plus qu'une maladresse parce que c'est
une manière de voir l'histoire sociale
qui est vraiment anormal et qui ne
correspond pas à la réalité c'est vrai
que le pas aimé c'est la fête des
travailleurs non pas pour se reposer
mais pour sanctionner pour montrer que
les luttes en payer et qu'une grande
partie notre système social tient grâce
à eux
ce que ce que je voudrais dire sur ce
que bon il ya beaucoup de protestations
d'amour d'amitié pour ces braves gens
qui se dépensent pour nous mais ce qu'il
faudrait maintenant c'est passé a des
preuves d'amour
la revalorisation des salaires pour tous
ses salariés en difficulté a basculé
dans le secteur de la santé n'est pas
seulement le retrait de cette réforme
des retraites qui a rejeté par 75% des
gens et il faut maintenant passer à de
véritables preuves d'amour
on ne peut pas se contenter gratuitement
d'annoncer que l'on aime les gens et ça
ne suffit pas il faut leur prouver qu'on
les aime
florian philippot ce mot chamailleurs
qu'en pensez vous enfin qui se
chamaillent se sent à qui on reproche de
ce chevalier les enfants ont dit dans la
classe on dit arrêtez de vous chamailler
quand il ya du bruit donc cesser c'est
typique de cette infantilisation du
peuple français à laquelle nous sommes
habitués de la part de ces gens vous
savez là on est on est tous enfermés
chez nous on les confie
et on a entendu le premier ministre et
le ministre de la santé nous dire soyez
bien sage parce que sinon vous serez pas
des confiner le 11 mai on est
infantilisé là le président de la
république infantilise les luttes
sociales historiques effectivement du
1er mai en parlant de chamailleries moi
je pense que c'est fait exprès je suis
pas sûr que ce soit une maladresse
moi je pense que c'est un champ
sémantique très cohérent qui montre que
ben voilà le peuple français ce sont
maintenant des enfants qui ont intérêt à
être plutôt disciplinés plutôt
obéissante plutôt sage 1 et puis sages
comme des images et puis comme ça ils
auront une récompense et un bon proie
bah c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
et il serait bien que le prénom d'un
public et son gouvernement sans s'en
rendre compte et je serais tout à fait à
cette idée qu'il faut maintenant des
preuves des preuves d'amour qu'on attend
et non pas que ce soit toujours les
mêmes qui tirent les marrons du feu
après la crise vous savez la crise de
2008 c'étaient les marchés financiers et
les boursicoteurs qui s'étaient enrichis
à la fin parce que c'est eux qu'on avait
renflouées avec l'argent des
contribuables
ben là c'est la france du travail réel
de l'économie vers qui va falloir
renflouer et non pas les boursicoteurs
on va parler de la reprise du travail un
pas pour ces personnes puisqu'elles
n'ont pas cessé de travailler un ces
personnes qui ont tenu le payer à bout
de bras jusqu'ici
qu'est-ce que ça va changer on va
d'abord écouter bruno le maire qui dit
que c'est urgent de reprendre le travail
onze engageons la deuxième période qui
est celle ouverte par le premier
ministre du retour l'activité je le
redis il faut reprendre le travail
il faut que le maximum de français
reprennent le travail donc un maximum de
français reprennent le travail jean paul
huchon
qu'en pensez vous ou est ce que c'est
possible dans de bonnes conditions
sachant que déjà une partie de la france
travaille je crois que ça sera possible
si on est capable d'offrir des
conditions de travail qui permettent à
tout le monde on de travail ce n'est pas
le cas pour les masquer ce n'est pas le
cas au lieu de test et ce n'est pas le
cas pour l'organisation notamment dans
les écoles donc c'est cesser c'est
gentil de dire il faut que tout le monde
revienne israël tout le monde a envie de
revenir au travail
oubliez chômeurs partiels il ne touche
que 84 % de leurs revenus et encore
aujourd'hui on dit que peut-être 7e
ces deux règles va être chamboulée à la
baisse bien entendu donc je crois qu'il
faut faire très attention
le travail ne peut reprendre que si le
gouvernement donne les moyens de
véritablement reprendre le travail et il
ne répond pas sur place d'autres
questions en particulier la reprise de
l'école est par ailleurs cette hypothèse
bizarre de dire va refaire deux tours le
municipal au mois de juin où les goûts
peut-être au mois de septembre octobre
tout ça n'est n'est pas c'est pas
l'essentiel de ce qui se passe lors huit
essences il sait qu'à lyon qui peuvent
mourir et beaucoup sont morts déjà on
sait que le nombre de morts est sans
doute inférieur à celui qu'on a déclaré
donc il faut vraiment que sur les
masques sur toutes les précautions
venu au travail d'ailleurs les
entreprises elles mêmes ne cherche pas à
forcer un parce qu'elles savent très
bien que le riche qu'elle rendrait qui
confesse juridictionnelle serait sûr est
lourd et comprendre aussi pourquoi les
maires sont assez réticents sur un
certain nombre de sujets c'est parce que
ils n'ont pas du tout envie d'être faire
l'objet de recours judiciaires c'est un
sujet très important
la cfdt fo la cfdt à apurer un sondage
qui dit 96 % des ouvriers travaillent
sur leur lieu de travail contrairement
aux cadres à 32%
ils sont sur le lieu de travail mais les
autres sont en télétravail donc c'est
que ce sont ces gens là qui vont prendre
des risques florian philippot oui
incontestablement c'est vrai qu'il est
aujourd'hui plus confortable d'être en
télétravail même si ça aussi c'est un
cours ayant fait que l'être sur sur le
terrain parce que j'ai envie de dire si
vous laissez que le gouvernement moi que
les gens reprennent le travail
je pense que c'est nécessaire il faut
pas que la france s'effondre non plus
parce que vous savez le nombre le nombre
de morts qui serait lié à une crise
économique absolument ahurissante
risquerait presque supérieur à la crise
sanitaire simplement mais il faut le
faire évidemment dans toutes les
conditions de sécurité
c'est ce gouvernement qui responsables
de l'acheminement des masques de des
tests de dépistage qui doit avoir enfin
une réflexion quand même urgente sur les
traitements géante le travail sur leur
lieu de travail c'est l'employeur qui
doit assurer la sécurité de ses employés
ouais d'accord ma famille en france il
ya un ministère de la santé il ya quand
même une organisation peut pas laisser
les employeurs comme ça seul démunis
surtout s'il continue d'avoir une
pénurie de masques et de tests dans
notre pays donc si vous voulez il faut
réfléchir à l'école faut réfléchir aux
transports comment on va faire pour
transporter mais tous ces gens là ça ce
sont de vraies réflexions et c'est vrai
qu'on a depuis le départ de ces prisons
gouvernement qui n'a pas réfléchi à tout
cela et puis il faut quand même parler
aussi des indépendants qui devront se
demander simplement si leur travail
existera encore parce que tous les
restaurateurs les cafés et les bars les
commerces cetera qui sont fermés depuis
des semaines malheureusement certains ne
rouvriront jamais et donc le la question
se pose même pas ils pourront parfaire
le travail reprend le travail parce que
tout simplement leur travail aura été
détruits donc qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
eux qu'est ce qu'on fait pour assurer la
réouverture de tous est indépendante de
tous ces commerces de tous ses
restaurants et ses bas c'est aussi une
vraie question est là je crois que la
réponse économique du gouvernement est
en-deça de ceux de ce qu'on attendrait
de ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs dans
d'autres pays qui met davantage les
moyens pourraient sauver sauvegarder ce
tissu d'emploi absolument indispensable
d'ailleurs plus d'un tissu dans potes et
aussi notre cadre de vie
nos restaurants de cafés c'est aussi
notre cadre de vie et le commerce de
centre-ville et 8 salariés sur 10 jean
paul huchon pense effectivement cette
crise aura une incidence sur sur sur le
travail c'est votre sentiment il y aura
de la casse est un gros risque pour les
indépendants comme vient de le dire mais
aussi pour des petites et moyennes
entreprises qui vont pas franchir la
barre parce que et c'est bien d'avoir
engagé des prêts avec à renty jetta
extra mais dans le concret je crois que
les entreprises qui sont en difficulté
se rendent bien compte qu'elles n'ont
pas une réponse ultra politique des
banques donc il ya beaucoup gars risque
déjà - 8 % de pib dans l'année c'est ce
qui a été annoncé par lula
je pense que ça arrive je peux être plus
ici ça risque d'être plus alors on va se
retrouver avec une remontée massive du
chômage sans recours parce que je ne
crois pas que la question du chômage
partiel pourra être prolongé
indéfiniment
on voit bien que déjà le gouvernement
dit bah il va peut-être falloir diminuer
l'indemnisation donc je suis préoccupé
parce que j'ai l'impression que la crise
économique va devenir encore plus
dangereuse qu'une crise sanitaire sur
laquelle on continue à se disputer et
sur les origines et sur les moyens de la
delà de la règle et donc il ya vraiment
eu une situation extrêmement
préoccupante je parle même pas de
l'échéance qui est celle des vacances
pour des gens qui ont beaucoup souffert
et donc personne ne leur dit jamais
comment ça va se passer ça c'est un
petit peu trop tôt encore pour pour le
déterminer
pas de pas de prêt de l'état si les
entreprises verser des dividendes vous
parliez des prêts de l'état
jean paul huchon florian philippot est
ce que l'état a eu raison de
conditionner ses aides au versement des
dividendes et est ce que ce sera
respectée selon vous ça c'est quand même
pour moi la moindre des choses puisque
les traits et viennent quand même de
l'argent public donc il serait quand
même aberrant de voir des versements de
dividendes
bon par ailleurs bruno le maire avait
dit pas de prêt non plus pour les
entreprises qui auraient des filiales ou
leur siège dans des paradis fiscaux
bon le problème c'est qu'on a appris
ensuite que ça concernait pas le
luxembourg l'irlande sert des paradis
fiscaux dans l'union européenne
donc si bout malte ce qui concerne pour
m l'essentiel des l'utilisation des
paradis fiscaux
aujourd'hui moi le concernant la
question qui à bord du jean pollution
sur le financement par le parler lui par
les banques parce que c'est vrai que
beaucoup de pme se tourner vers leurs
banques
je pense qu'une des mesures un peu
révolutionnaire pour va devoir prendre
ça qu'il l'est pas tant que ça en
réalité ça nous paraît aujourd'hui
dengue dans le logiciel macro nist mais
c'est le ba sud c'est la nationalisation
du secteur bancaire moi je pense qu'on a
three baptisé à mon avis beaucoup trop
rapidement à partir des années 80
quasiment toutes les banques toutes les
banques et les assurances d'ailleurs je
pense qu'on a besoin d'un pool bancaire
et assurantiel plus
nick et on va se rendre compte en fait
qu'on a besoin d'un état puissant qui
interviennent aussi pour réguler
l'économie notamment en période de crise
n'est pas simplement c'est votre ami
jean paul huchon
j'ai jamais été un grand fan des
nationalisations
alors que les pop aux amis politiques il
ya on était partisan il est évident que
pour des industries ou des donc
absolument stratégique
la question de leur mise sous contrôle
se pose c'est sûr qu'au moment je trouve
qu'ils n'ont pas si mal réagi il faut
voir si il va y avoir à la fois des
réticences des impossibilités de fer et
l'enthousiasmé au début le dis on va
aider tout le monde et ksar il faut que
ça se maintiennent sur la durée surtout
si la date du 11 mai et plus ou moins
plus ou moins reculé donc je suis
partisan aussi une position assez forte
les dividendes oui c'est quand même
normal je reste sur mon confrère on
ferait vraiment très curieux si on
continue à laisser les gens faire des 80
alors que ils ont utilisé l'argent de
l'état c'est une forme de
nationalisation du crédit c'est
exactement ce qu alli makoun gladu on a
pratiquement nationalisé le crédit va
écouter ça ne peut pas durer une
éternité
et ce n'est semble pas ce qu'il faut
imaginer à l'avenir
florian philippot pour cette reprise du
travail prévue à partir du 11 mai pour
certains est ce que l'état ne joue pas
là la corde de la peur finalement à
outrance puisqu'il faut remettre les
personnes au travail mais après deux
mois de confinement
certains peuvent se dire j'y retourne
pas pas forcément par la peur de la
maladie mais aussi parce qu'ils se sont
habitués à rester chez eux alors la
question de la peur dans la gestion
publique des populations c'est une vraie
question
on sait bien qui a toujours une
tentation il peut y avoir une tentation
de la part de certains gouvernements de
maintenir la peur parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya un peuple qui a peur c'est un
peuple moins revendicatif
c'est un peu moins chamailleurs on va
dire pour reprendre le mot de d'emmanuel
makfoul mois
un turbulent pour prendre un autre mot
infantilisant mais si vous voulez c'est
pas un mythe vérité est donc là il va
falloir être extrêmement vigilant j'ai
vu qu'on va on va encore reporté de deux
mois à l'état d'urgence sanitaire
je me pose des questions parce qu'il ya
quand même aussi des des
épidémiologistes ans le professeur raoul
pour pas le citer qui disent que
normalement bon les infections
respiratoires jeunesse des phénomènes de
cloche est con et qu'il ya quand même
peu de risque d'une deuxième vague alors
tout ce que je dis là je vais pas je
suis pas de la prévision moi je crois en
débattra bien sûr oui mais simplement je
pense qu'il faut faire
effectivement extrêmement attention à
cette instrumentalisation de la peur par
le gouvernement parce que je pense que
c'est une vraie question politique
absolument fondamental le gouvernement
aussi peu s'accoutumer aux eaux à des
techniques de maintien de l'ordre en
quelque sorte de la peine au civil par
la peur et la deuxième question c'est
qu'on peut pas demander aux gens non
plus d'aller travailler ou d'aller avec
leurs enfants à l'école je ne sais quoi
si on leur fournit pas les masques moi
je pense qu'il faudrait fournir du
masque - plus massivement et puis rendre
le port du masque obligatoire comme
l'ont fait d'autres pays
ça fonctionne bien et ça n'est pas c'est
plutôt acceptée par les français de
porter le masque
je voudrais que jean paul huchon
répondre à cette question est ce que
finalement certains français ne voudront
plus retourner travailler après ces deux
mois de de confinement chez eux
vous avez 30 secondes il ya un vrai
risque que psychologiquement les gens se
sentent un peu perdus un peu paumée mais
enfin quand même la nécessité fait loi
il va falloir continuer à travailler
gagner un peu d'argent pour subvenir aux
besoins des familles je n'y crois pas
trop ces suspects se d'échappatoire
arctique
mais si ça commence à se produire il va
falloir là aussi que l'état donne un
coup de main à ceux qui sont plus en
difficulté
la question d'un espèce de garantie
minimum de revenus continuent à se poser
sans doute maintenant merci beaucoup
jean paul huchon et merci à vous florian
philippot d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de votre fidélité restez
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]